all right okay so I'm going to combine
my my welcome with my presentation so I
just need one of my tech people to tell
me oh oh I advanced this this way this
is how we do it okay so welcome to the
third annual health disparities carb as
a teacher's college and I'm going to be
addressing the conference theme toward
Global Health Transformation research
demonstration projects and model
interventions for I just lost them on
the screen then we need the tech people
already just touch the screen thank you
and model interventions to reduce
disparities in health as you can see i'm
also the conference director and
professor of health education we're
really going to save time today by not
doing formal introductions of our
speakers so you can see our keynote
speakers and featured speakers and the
way in which we have their biographies
in the conference program and then of
course we ask you to do with most of the
world is doing and that is to google the
names of our various featured and
keynote and other panelists and workshop
leaders and indeed to find out all the
details there are and all the links to
their journal articles and publications
so in terms of my welcome i would just
like to say that part of what we intend
to do at this conference today and
tomorrow is to really describe regional
national and global work we're going to
focus on research on closing gaps in
education as well as closing gaps in
health as well as closing gaps in
capacity so that some of the talks are
going to talk about the way in which but
in which we need to do capacity building
for research community empowerment so
that communities can self determine
their own health and so you'll see
researchers talking about how they are
building capacity by training researches
and researchers in places such as
Central Asia as well as training peer
educators and so they're also our
demonstration projects some of which
overlap with that research and so we'll
have speakers talking about their work
in New York City powerful demonstration
projects across the United States as
well as globally in places such as in
the Virgin Islands Africa Central Adria
etc so you can peruse the program to get
a full picture of that which I speak and
so also there are in your conference
program little symbols so there is a
tool box that is aside various
activities alerting to you to the first
point here which is that in many
sessions our goal is to provide tools
for you use for your use in your work so
that you end up having something akin to
a newly equipped toolbox we have a heart
symbol for those sessions dealing the
special populations of the kind you see
listed and we also have community
members who will be celebrating Women's
History Month we ask all of you to
support the health of women and
encourage them to access health care and
free screenings at our community health
fair so you will see a symbol of the
female symbol sign next to those
sessions and for example we're also
going to be having an Internet table of
community health fair where you can
actually take a survey we have expanded
the diva health org survey which debuted
this time last year it's now been
expanded to have a Haitian station where
we have over 6 vo videos in Creole with
role plays as well as another 19 that
our educational translated into creo we
have a beauty shop station urging beauty
shop owners to transform their beauty
shops in two places where there are
internet to access facilities so that
they can feature the diva health org
website as well as the capacity building
station which is going to be launched
for tomorrow as well and in this
capacity building station individuals
can actually take the training that's
been codified in a book on sale back
there which is hiv/aids prevention pure
education training and this capacity
building exercise allows them to go to
the book online and within a couple of
months we're going to be able to issue a
test that they can take and certificate
so we're tempting to foster
international internet based training of
peer educators to build capacity and
then we have
the AIDS ribbon acknowledging sessions
devoted to hiv/aids and again at our
health fair even if it's raining and the
wind is blowing we're going to have the
sheet lined with vans three imagine
three rapid testing facilities that are
going to be available in comfortable
dance as well as mammograms we have US
doctors for Africa that is a symbol for
sessions we have some guests coming who
are working on developing a regional
initiative as well as psychosocial
interventions for those who are devoted
to going to Africa and expanding the
initiatives of doctors who are going to
operate mobile clinic vans in Africa to
basically meet the needs for medical
care in Africa so that symbol usdf a
signifies those sessions and then we
have youth we have a health disparities
Academy many of those youth are in
school now so or college taking their
college courses and so many will show up
at various points later today or
tomorrow so the ideas that we're
committed to fostering a pipeline and
therefore we're having a hip-hop panel
in a cultural show that's going to occur
doing our reception they're going to
have a hip-hop panel from 4 to 5 30
excuse me for me 45 to whatever
those times are please forgive me it's
in your it's in your little program and
then we're going to have the cultural
show which is from 5 to 6 30 at our
reception so that is an accurate figure
ok so our conference symbol what are we
all about we're really about moving from
an equity and health to equity in health
and this is a symbol that basically
represents the research group on
disparities in health we're also using
this symbol to remind all of you the
part of what we're doing is launching a
new field of equity in health and we're
fostering the 21st century global civil
rights movement for equity in health for
all so part of what we're doing today is
we're putting out a conference call for
a new global civil rights movement for
equity in health and educational access
for all and so I'm going to talk now
about the forces driving and embodied
within
a new field of equity and health so what
is this it's a commercial but it's also
the source for the information that I'm
going to be talking about today and so
we're very grateful to Springer
publications that they're offering a
one-time discount of 4995 for this book
toward equity and health a new global
approach to health disparities and
they're 31 chapters in this particular
edited volume these are the proceedings
of the first annual health disparities
conference in 2006 and they're at least
a dozen people in this room who have
chapters or if contributed as co off
those two chapters in this evident
volume so this is the time to get the
copies for your mother ok ok so now
let's talk about the very first chapter
which is the introduction forces driving
a global civil rights movement for
health and i'm actually delighted that
i'm sherry Sussman is here representing
Springer publications so be let's give
her a hand written thank her for that
discount today and thank her for the
contract for that Vulcan 2006 and who
knows maybe we'll get a contract for yet
another volume to come out of this
conference today so be very nice to a
Miss Sussman and I fell in love with her
when she read chapter one and called it
a tour de force so let's see if you like
it too okay so in terms of what we are
talking about in terms of launching this
new field of equity and help and the
driving forces as an introduction let's
consider what we're really talking about
we're talking about something as basic
as fundamental human values the value of
engaging in fairplay of acting with
impartiality of allowing a sense of
social justice to guide us so that we
can ensure that all human beings are
free to enjoy the right to health as
what was the pursuit of their physical
emotional mental and spiritual
well-being and of course diverse troops
are going to define that and elect to
pursue it as they may in addition we
could turn to the work of many others
for example that of brave men so that
what I'm talking about in this chapter
is really validated by a host of
research
teachers and scholars so I tried to them
and making the case for that which I
speak in this particular chapter and so
brave Minh does a wonderful job and
knowing noting that pursuing health
equity another word striving to
eliminate health disparities and no fair
note that we are really about is
shifting the discourse that we're very
much talking about what we want as
opposed to what we do not want we do not
want more health disparities heads we're
shifting the discourse or seeking to the
United States by talking about the
pursuit of health equity and so we're
talking about striving to eliminate
those disparities strongly associating
the social disadvantage and so it can be
thought of as striving for equal
opportunities for all social groups to
be as healthy as possible in addition
there's can be a selective focus other
words we are totally justified and
taking a selective focus on improving
conditions for those groups who have had
fewer opportunities removing obstacles
for those who have been poor
disadvantaged a persons who are not
heterosexual those who've been
historically facing various obstacles to
their rights to health and other human
rights so this is brave men talking here
addition come on little button we don't
have time for you to not want to talk
okay and then we're talking about a
global movement from an equity in health
equity in hell and so we can turn to the
work of Washington who in her book
Medical apartheid sites Donna Christian
Christensen who basically said health
disparities are of a civil rights issue
of the 21st century and also Washington
began her book by citing Martin Luther
King Jr who said of all the forms of
inequality injustice in health is the
most shocking and the most inhumane and
so we can also now justify why are we
talking about a global approach because
we now live in a community that is
indeed global that we travel and what we
observe through broadcast images using
technology can serve to alert a system
what's going on any part of the world we
could if we chose to rapidly mobilize
and take action to quickly respond to
literally any health issue or crisis and
literally any region of the globe
dispersing resources however we can also
see some evidence of a differential
interpretation that can occur with
regard to what is broadcast the images
that we see and so we see two examples
one in which we indeed indeed respond to
images of the Asian tsunami and we did
mobilize resources however there was a
lot more difficulty doing so when we
have Hurricane Katrina and so part of
what we need to appreciate is that some
of these differences and while the
extent to which there is a need for a
Global Health Transformation again think
of those values fair play for example
and so we need to value and pursue
equity in health for all as a global
interdependent community with vast
resources that are just so exposed and
again can we act with impartiality can
we allow a sense of social justice to
guide us so what is our work what is our
role what is the role of this conference
the idea is that in 2006 if you were
here you may recall that we declared a
decade of health disparity reduction and
so we talked about types of evidence how
we need to go beyond the gold standard
randomized clinical trial and also begin
to engage in community collaborations
partnerships and of course
community-based participatory research
and so today we are going to declare a
21st central global civil rights
movement for equity in hell for all and
so what are the forces before I ask you
to join in such a call perhaps you
deserve a rationale and so this is where
we can seek yet other evidence and focus
on the 13 forces that are driving this
and we're also going to talk for a
moment about the mechanism for
sustaining this movement and promoting a
new field of equity in health and so we
have the Journal of equity of Health
with a slide or something jumped around
us YT and PDF but any event as you can
see the inaugural issue is februari 2008
this is also going to be online and
available tomorrow at the Community
Health Fair that's the goal at least but
I have my webmaster working on about
five projects so we'll see how he does
and if indeed that occurs by tomorrow
health care and so what are these these
guiding principles these driving forces
there's a dry for a new major paradigm
shift a drive for new models of health
care and training the drive for new
theories perspectives and identities the
drive for evidence-based approaches the
drive for transdisciplinary teams and
community-based participatory research
to dry for globalization and global
collaboration the drive or cultural
competence and cultural appropriateness
the driver health literacy and
linguistic appropriateness the drive to
ensure the right to health the driver
social justice and acknowledgment of
forces in the social context the drive
to protect and support the most
vulnerable the drive to repair damage
restored trucks and take responsibility
and 13 to redistribute wealth and access
to opportunity and so let's review each
of these spending a little bit more or
less time on each one but since I'm
obsessed with the first one it'll have a
little bit more attention the driver a
major paradigm shift and so you also see
the a over B that is a part of the
research group symbol that's on your
conference program and so what does that
symbolize it symbolizes the extent to
which we need to stop that which does
not work anymore the paradigmatic
behavior in ways of being associated
with hierarchical domination and so a
over B any actor a above any actor be
put in the position below and so that is
a symbol of many relationships of
hierarchical domination more
specifically given any actor ady nectar
be the goal is to really conceptualize
the whole dynamic of hierarchical
authority and the way in which you can
foster oppression so you know some
examples
a master be slave a heterosexual be
sexual diversity and of course the way
of teaching that we're trying to move
away from a teacher lecturing all the
time and in position B student passive
recipient of knowledge and so what do we
want we want to move to a equals B and
so we need to realize if that is really
a symbol of higher Matt hierarchical
equality that's what we're talking about
and we get to a equals B so we're trying
to stop a over B and move to the new
paradigm and so what do we need to do
individually we all need a heightened
state of awareness in other words can we
catch ourselves in the act so to speak
to what extent can we engage in cell
observation or is the behaviors would
say self-monitoring can we stop any
behavior and so in this case it would be
those ways of thinking behaving being
the road associated with a over B can we
potentially stop and not only stop but
then go on to observe even ourselves or
organizations as we engage in those old
ways of thinking and behaving and then
after we stop can we actually create a
clearing or space for the emergence of
something new can we consciously direct
ourselves to execute new ways of
thinking behaving and being and since
professor Greer is here might even get
some positive reinforcement for doing so
and might we systematically rehearse and
be fine over time new ways of thinking
behaving and being so they become
automatic natural responses from which
we also get a sense of natural
reinforcement and gratification in other
words we engaged in fairplay it just
might feel good all of us living in the
aftermath of centuries of domination
impression we have been socially
conditioned in places such the United
States but we can bring about a new
paradigm of a equals B relationships of
equality freedom justice and all the
conditions for all reaching their full
human potential prevailing and so the
goal of interpersonal relationships
reflects this na
hierarchical state of equality or a
equals B thanking acknowledging the work
of Taylor and this non hierarchical
state of equality can be a desired
status and in fact come to characterize
all interpersonal and human interaction
globally so now the drive for new models
of health care and training so we're
talking about a shift here to a new
paradigm that includes new models of
healthcare new ways of training the oral
health care system medical field might
be in terms of our public health systems
also shift and might we challenge the
current hichem OD and some of these
models and also could we even begin to
value things such as prevention so these
are things that many of you in the
audience are ever so familiar with and
then third a dry for new theories
perspectives and identities and so the
new paradigm necessarily requires new
theories and new perspectives part of
what we're moving toward is literally a
menu of evidence-based approaches a menu
of integrated theories and approaches of
which we could choose and select and
Taylor interventions to meet the needs
of various diverse groups even as their
needs may change at various times we
need to avoid engaging in blame the
victim or deficit oriented research
where we conduct the kind of research
where we end up comparing let's say
blacks vs white sand or a white first
Hispanics etc etc and those who tend to
be in position a tend to look a lot
worse of all of those variables and we
have in effect mostly identified
variables internal to the person so even
though we did not intend to we may be
contributing to blame the victim
research more evidence of deficits
deficits deficits belonging to those in
position be historically who are most
vulnerable population groups and so
could we avoid locating such key
variables within the individual and so
it's really important that we begin to
focus on the role of the social context
so what are those social context factors
that go along with a over B such as the
hierarchical domination the forces of
oppression and of course the goal
socioeconomic status differences that
result and so how can we begin to really
focus on strengths assets as well as a
view many problem behaviors it's merely
attempts to coat and adapt in a
stressful social context and then we can
begin to talk about adaptive versus
maladaptive coping we can identify
adaptive ways of coping effectively
behaviorally and cognitively and create
interventions and disseminate those kind
of interventions so that others might
replace maladaptive coping with adaptive
coping our identities as researchers how
many of us in the process of reading all
those journal articles all of those
books ended up essentially being
socially conditioned into having an
identity as a professional that's very
tied up with our theory but what if that
theory doesn't apply another part of the
world with a particular population or
group and so to what extent do we need
to actually talk about a transformation
of the identity indeed to work with
communities around the globe we have to
assume responsibility for deconstructing
an identity that can be rooted in our
Western theories and for reconstituting
and rearranging our own identities the
goal is to create an identity so that we
can perceive that which is of value in a
social cultural context that may be new
to us and to actively seek to enter that
context through a gate that's
appropriate air high in bua talks about
can you go to Africa for example and
enter through a gate that comes from our
Western theories when we're entering the
brand new cultural context and so
there's also a drive for evidence-based
approaches so it's crucial to move
toward a menu of evidence-based
approaches so to the extent that in 2006
we declared a decade of health disparity
reduction research the goal is that
we're going to be able to generate a
menu of evidence-based approaches for
each challenge that we face and of
course this is the evidence-based
approach that standard in most fields
the goal is to generate this
evidence-based
approach a decade by decade and
eventually we can certainly embrace the
goal of eliminating these disparities
and then there's a dry for
transdisciplinary teams and
community-based participatory research
and so imagine that we need to conduct
research from multiple perspectives that
are blocks the table when we truly have
representatives of different disciplines
there as well as stakeholders community
members at the table part of the reason
that this conference is structured in
the manner in which it is is because we
have a last name Columbia University and
sometimes people might if we did a
little Free Association test right now
some of you might have think eminent
domain record shop closing in Harlem so
the idea is that to the extent that we
have that last name we're having this to
be healthier too very much repair and
he'll relations because we need
community partners we need to partner
with community-based organizations with
our clinics our hospitals our nonprofit
organizations our churches because they
are the members of the community groups
that we need at the table is key
stakeholders so we are partnering with
them here within this conference and
opening up for example the Saturday for
25 30 session to any community member
who like to come to any of those
sessions so in this way we need to
appreciate that professionals and
community members have to enjoy mutual
respect and recognition as well as a
free-flowing dialogue among equals those
are key aspects of the new paradigm and
so we need also to have community
members involved from the very beginning
of the process from conceptualization of
research so for example we have nabila
alba CEO of the School of Social Work
and her colleagues who are going to be
presenting tomorrow her colleagues will
be representing her but they have done
excellent evidence-based research come
up with the models that have been
embraced for dissemination nationally
and globally and they can describe
involving community members from the
very beginning conceptualization
implementation dissemination the goal is
to
what critical errors we may misrepresent
the reality of the groups of people with
whom we work the drive for globalization
and global collaboration the internet
and new technology certainly make us a
little community and so if we are bound
together by forces of globalization and
we have things such as a world economy
politics culture human affairs there's
probably more excitement and more
conversation in some parts of the room
about our current election campaign
because we are a global community and
images are being broadcast around the
world not only of disasters but also our
everyday human affairs but we need a new
definition of globalization and so this
is where I actually take from a book
that not a cross-eyed waffle has put out
and so she was the master the female
master drummer who performed with her
African drummers but in the back of the
ball and back in the room there's a book
called tigger a speaks we're basically
what I take from there is the concept
that what affects one affects all so in
that particular book two great speaks
iwako 2005 is talking about values
african healing wisdom values that can
direct us and so to what extent do we
possess a consciousness that what
affects one affects all and we can make
a multiple examples we may not care
about what another country is doing or
another state is doing until we have
acid rain going from New Jersey to
Canada we might not care about global
warming until of course we find that we
are more vulnerable to a hurricane or a
tornado or to a disaster so the idea is
that what affects one affects all and
it's the consciousness of our
fundamental interdependence as a global
community as well as the resulting
process of learning to work
collaboratively and to share and
disperse resources within our global
community to ensure social justice
equity the protection of human rights
and the sustainability of the planet
makes very much sense if we don't have a
planet that is not well and so this is
something that's offered as we think
about the drive from globalization and
how we might cognitively be fraying
globalization the drive for cultural
competence and cultural appropriateness
there's a drive or cultural competence
and cultural appropriate asst this is
something that is driven here at
Teachers College our very own
multicultural counseling focus and the
Department of calcium clinical
psychology we have some of the very best
experts in the world here from darell
bingsoo to Madonna Constantine to Robert
Carter and so the idea is that to what
extent do we not have to reinvent the
wheel there is tremendous scholarship in
terms of help to drain counseling
psychologists to be multicultural e
competent we can draw upon this and
ensuring that our physicians our nurses
our health educators that all who are
going to work in this illness of this
movement to bring about equity hell for
all than all of them possess cultural
competence and are going to engage in
demonstration projects and research that
is culturally appropriate we cannot just
take a grant funded in 2002 that we
implemented in the wrong dust it off and
send it off and say we're now going to
do this in 20 places in Africa and
absolutely no modifications okay so it
becomes absurd but might get you funded
probe's gotten some people funded but
the idea is to what extent do we need to
really think about cultural
appropriateness do we have the
representatives the stakeholders at the
table from the very beginning and we
discuss and we adapt and we closely
Taylor things so that they are
appropriate so then corded I'll explain
cultural poopiness cultural competence
as a strategy to improve quality and
eliminate racial disparities in
healthcare okay so of course the goal is
to deliver
highest quality care to every patient
regardless a race ethnicity culture or
language proficiency the driver health
literacy linguistic appropriateness we
see this most powerfully and in our
emergency rooms too extensively become
here in New York City a magnet for
immigrants fell over the world arrived
at the emergency room oh okay could your
seven-year-old child please translate
for the 65 year old grandfather who has
once described his prostate problems you
know doesn't quite work very well so to
what extent do we need to follow the
association american medical colleges
and the way that they have sought to
ensure training that produces both
cultural linguistic competence we're
going to hear from maria Morzan tomorrow
who basically along with myself as her
sponsor did a wonderful job oriented in
adapting their guidelines to create a
tool that was given to medical students
upon entrance and can also be given post
their medical education where they were
asked to evaluate their own knowledge
skills attitudes against all those
competencies that they identify and also
how they rate the importance for their
medical school education so you may want
to hear those results from maria
tomorrow and of course health literacy
and linguistic appropriate is our vital
considerations because how can we
deliver any health information ND a
central task of all of us in this room
is delivering health education our
medical practitioners and all of those
who are working in these disease
prevention and health education so that
is absolutely critical the drive to
ensure the right to health the Public
Health Association the American Public
Health Association certainly has
embraced this as an absolutely critical
goal so that the discourse on the right
to health is sunny that's been going on
globally for quite a while now and so
the idea is that closely align with the
right to health is the right to
determine what constitutes help whatever
helps
it's outcomes way of life so we have to
respect and accept members of diverse
cultures and their right to
self-determination and so that's an
overarching principle operating here the
individuals groups communities can self
determine their own health their own
health outcomes and ideally are
empowered so that they can sustain that
which will help them to self-determine
their health and so it's evidence of
this drive we can turn to the work of
brave man again who talks about how the
foundations for addressing health
disparities and pursuing health equity
come not only from an ethics but also
from the field of international human
rights and so we're talking about those
rights are in Taliban's entitlements
that all people in the world have
regardless of who they are or where they
live so the right to health is becoming
a global fundamental concept the dry for
social justice and acknowledgement of
forces in the social context and so here
again we see talked about the right to
health and also social justice that
these are going to go hand in hand
whenever we talk about equity and that
is crucial to pay attention to the
social context the social justice piece
goes hand-in-hand with training because
we need to inculcate in professional and
personal identities assess that one is
not only a health educator what is not
only a psychologist or a nurse or a
teacher but that an additional dimension
of your identity as a professional and
as a community members should be a
willingness to take social action for
social justice and then we also have the
work of others dietrichson it out the
ideas that we now talk about the social
context there are certain kinds of
social context factors those involving
social stratification those that involve
differential exposure to help damaging
factories where do we put our
incinerators for example in what kind of
communities what about differential
exposure where do the diesel trucks go
how is it
we have such high rates of asthma what
environmental factors might be involved
so there can be differential
vulnerabilities this acceptability that
can also follow from differential
exposure and again the result could be
unequal health outcomes and differential
consequences of illness the drive to
protect and support the most vulnerable
again we would have to have that
consciousness that what affects one
affects all it would have to have that
consciousness about our fundamental
interdependence we would have to
therefore with such a consciousness
focus on those who are the most
vulnerable and they tended me
populations or groups defined by racial
or ethnic status or socio-economic
position or age or gender or sexual
orientation or other perceive population
of group characteristics and we're also
talking about all of those groups that
tend to be negatively stereotyped and
stigmatized as what was targets of hate
and violence so there is diversity and
the kind of projects that for example
the students in the department of health
behavior studies are those associated
with the research group on disparities
in health can focus on okay in other
words there can be virtually any group
of justifiably serving as a focus given
how they may be targets of hate and
violence and so here the United States
we would say that among our most
vulnerable particularly in recent
decades would be the incarcerated black
males in particular but we also have
global policies that create new
vulnerable groups and so these policies
involve more violence global warming
government corruption lack of access to
essential public health or medical
services and of course the emotion of
civil liberties and freedoms that occurs
and so there are many kinds of social
conditions that can end up creating new
vulnerable a shin so under principle 11
we would follow a drive to protect and
support the most vulnerable and then of
course the drive to repair damage
restore trust and take responsibility
I'm
Rachel of damage has been done and that
includes a host of negative consequences
experienced by those subject to forces
of oppression remember that a over me
paradigm who has historically suffered
and so how do we begin to repair damage
every store trust and take
responsibility and a number of authors
have addressed this theme we will just
identify a few and damage is spelled
with 2 a's okay XO we turn to the work
of Randall and in terms of the work of
Randall he locates the distraction of
trust in the medical and health this is
a woman this is a black woman I
apologize look at that social
conditioning Randall E no Randall is a
black woman Randall locates the
destruction of trust in the medical and
health care system as well as the
medical personnel and researches within
the long history of medical
experimentation the United States on
blacks prisoners and members of the
Armed Forces and so there's a deep dish
trust that she talks about is literally
in the consciousness of the black
community and that contributes to
disparities in health because he may not
seek out care etc in the same day in
Washington again in her book medical
apartheid does the same kind of detailed
history of that experimentation on black
standing back to colonial times
surgeries that were performed on women
for example to perfect ghana logical
procedures the abuse of enslaved
african-americans and lo and behold we
might not know but Washington documents
how it continues up to the present day
there's still forced experimentation on
prison inmates soldiers in the armed
forces and the emotion of informed
consent so experimental procedures are
used in emergency rooms or
non-consenting victims and so she talks
about a deep-seated fear another words
black aya trope I atrophic Ida a fear of
medicine and so Washington goes to step
further in terms of her vision of
medical research education how do we
restore it she's suggesting this medical
research education which would include
making accessible excuse me to lay
people l'ducation that would cover
medical research assist
navigating clinical trials we can have
brochures websites access to experts
that's made readily available we could
also have church health fairs social
organizations community activism so
indeed we're even going to have someone
at the committee health fair tomorrow
who's going to be talking about a
potential trial and so the idea is that
to an extent do we have organized
activities that help people to navigate
and to become educated about those
trials even better community members
should actually be joining institutional
review boards and asking the difficult
hard questions and if the questions and
the answers go well to actually
encourage members of diverse communities
to participate in trials and so finally
the need for african-american septum on
research agendas as an ultimate avenue
for taking responsibility so we would
like to look at the annual health
disparities conference and our diverse
team that came together and
conceptualize this conference with
people such as dr. OB deng be dr. fully
love dr. alene and many individuals such
as dr. Jessica Adams Skinner who's going
to be a great researcher in coming years
that this very diverse group including
at Gordon a visa to urban a minority
education we envision all the components
across a series of meetings and what was
at the heart of this also was the idea
that this could also be a place for
sitting research agendas which is why at
2006 and that particular conference we
put out the call that we did for a
decade of evidence-based research to
reduce health disparities other factors
involves socha na makalah see the drive
to redistribute wealth and access to
opportunity who would think that so many
research studies ended up concluding
today that not only is there a robust
effect of income on health evident in
many different ways as you can see but
the idea that um those who have less
income certainly tend to be more
disabled live less healthy lives and
Diet younger ages and so part of what
cahuachi it out talk about is how race
has been
use to really divide us and that what's
really needed is a class consciousness
and if we have this kind of class
consciousness the idea is that we might
have social solidarity if you see in
that third bullet there and the bottom
line is that if we can achieve that
social solidarity then we might
understand why so much research that
concludes that we needed redistribute
income and also ensure equal access to
educational and employment opportunity
that it needs to come about through
something such as a movement that cuts
across race lines and that allows us to
experience a very broad type of
solidarity across all lines and so the
idea is that if we r divided we can fail
to see our common interests instead
there are values then brave and identify
such as distributive justice
distributive justice as the equitable
allocation of resources in a society and
so there is a drive to redistribute
wealth and access to opportunity so as
we move toward can car conclusion of
this particular opening address what is
it that we need i would say that we need
to move from an equity in health to
equity in health and to shift our
discourse and talk more and more about
what we want which is equity in health
to launch this new field of equity help
the link through the volume that
Springer has published but also in the
online journal why and one why journal
because it represents the equitable
access that we're talking about that one
need not purchase a subscription to an
expensive journal for example and then
ultimately a 21st century global civil
rights movement for equity in health for
all and so today we declare a 21st
century global civil rights movement for
equity in hell for all and I invite all
to repeat with me the next two bullets
are you ready I am calling for
21st century gullible civil rights
movement for equity you hell for all
okay guy be better than that we're going
to say two more times ready here we go I
am calling for a 21st century global
civil rights movement for equity in hell
for all one more time I am calling for
21st century global civil rights
movement for equity in hell for all I'm
only saying once I am committed to
taking action to ensure the right to
hell and so now this is an affirmation
for you what does commitment me it means
I am who I say I am I do what I say I'm
going to do if I ever failed to be or do
what I said I would I apologize and be
committed because we're human and in
this human condition we tend sometimes
to make mistakes and so what's needed
then forgiveness apology so we can go to
I waffles book to your a speaks not only
that value then what affects one affects
all but the value of interdependence
apology pardoning forgiveness you see
you can pardon someone that's a little
bit less emotional okay but to forgive a
little bit more emotional but to
apologize and so this is some of the
values coming from the African healing
listen that can guide us and so that's
the book apology pardon forgiveness
interdependence and so what am I now
thinking you for I thank you for your
commitment for welcoming and measuring
the youth are going to be here
particularly tomorrow from college from
Kingsville College other places because
we need to create a pipeline I thank you
for welcoming our community members and
to foster that healing with our
community members who are a guest so
that we can develop community
partnerships based on mutual respect and
recognition and I thank you for your
presence of all of our events today and
tomorrow let's give ourselves a hand
thank you okay
our place nine and so now we're going to
have professor Doug Greer who is this
bio is in your book and you can google
his name and read everything if you have
a few hours but I would just like to say
that even as teachers collar searches
for models because teachers college
would like to have a school and yeah
they can travel to Philadelphia they can
travel all over the nation and look for
viable models but I tell you that in the
work professor Greer we have something
that could make our homepage model
education low equity whatever it is
educated what is our homepage say who
wants to get extra credit okay any event
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu